you know um when you're getting your 50
like
you start thinking about um
your whole um life ex expectation okay
that um i'm gonna die so you know
sometimes i come from the gym i'm
working out i take a couple of mushrooms
before i work out right so i'm working
out i'm pumped up looking at myself in
the mirror just really going for it on
the treadmill and then um
i go in the
shower
i look in the mirror i'm flexing and the
shoes
and this is this is speeding the process
by working out this damn heart and then
i start freaking out a little bit wait
now are you are you taking shrooms
before the workout just because you like
the the space of thinking that comes oh
absolutely okay the focusness of shrooms
you can't compare to nothing now okay
but um
and that affects me with the fact that
we're gonna die
and i went through that process by
taking certain um natural medicine
and um it was beautiful
now you're still you're still very much
a physical guy like you're talking about
working out right you're talking about
still being healthy you're still talking
about getting up and getting after to
some degree for you
so granted yeah shrooms play a part in
you thinking about death are you
thinking about the end um
i'm asking you right now
there's got to be some type of
realization or recognition to
to just what you've done what you've
overcome
where you sit at now i know that that's
my ego that part that i'm talking about
yeah that's my ego okay i'm talking
about all that i've accomplished and i
outlived this guy i've became that's all
[ __ ] okay yeah so you don't you
don't there is no world of thought when
it comes to that you put the ego to the
side
periodically
you know the ego itself is
thought-provoking and it allows you to
really
understand the necessarily need of it
if we didn't have our ego we'd be on
we'd be in the corner we'll be a wreck
you